thank you for this introduction
good morning to everybody it's really
i'm really excited and it's really a
pleasure to to present in front of such
a
say vibrant and dynamic community as a
partner community is and
um i have to admit i became a python fan
several years ago
and let's say before i continue with
that
and this is maybe a little part of the
the presentation which is also a very
personal perspective i have to admit so
it's maybe
let's say not a purely academic approach
but
um i just wanted to share some ideas and
when eve asked me a while ago felix
would you like to present to the
pie data in london it's yeah i still
have time to prepare a presentation
no worries and i immediately said yes
and then 24 hours i thought oh felix
what have you done you have no idea
what to talk about so well i i hope that
it's
um i can give you maybe some insights
and it's it's for me it's more a
discussion
um template if you want um i'm not yet
having in my mind all the solutions but
i believe that let's say python has a
great potential uh in the industry and
um especially the perspective i'm having
now in my current role
at deutsche birth group um i'm i'm
convinced that we we can
can take a lot out of it so few seconds
about myself um i started with deutsche
birth group in
1992 so for let's say from that
perspective i'm already
a dinosaur um and still not extinct but
working on it
and um let's say that i i was not only
there yeah so i have to i say i'm
i had the pleasure uh to work also with
uh
also on the other side of of the fence
um and also looking at the
at the exchange or at the marketplace uh
from a customer side and i worked
several years for a swiss hedge fund so
i learned let's say from from both
perspectives
and then i returned in 2006
and uh yeah let's say basically um
you're some so there seems to be um that
this seems to be somehow a pattern that
you're always returning to the place of
crime yeah so
um i i couldn't i was not able to to to
fully
uh let's say leave this company so
the idea of today is um to give you a
perspective on on what i think is is a
great potential
uh for for python and um
i i recap a little bit the abstract
which you all of you know but just to
give you a little bit of of background
how i came to it
so um what i'm facing myself and this is
basically a regular reflection of my own
experience
is we we have a financial industry which
is evolving
an increasing increasing pace and also
when i look at my colleagues who are
taking care of our data warehouse
let's say the the factor uh of of of
let's say of growth that we or can
observe
in data is tremendous yeah so when when
um we plan to have a current project
which um
it's called prisma which is a
portfolio-based risk
margining system um and and just to give
you a flavor i mean when when we started
the planning and the first
if you want modeling of of the system um
let's say we thought about a certain
dimension of data
a certain amount of data and nowadays
it's
18 times larger than the projected one
and this is probably not the end it will
become more yeah so
so i think that this is one of the
dimensions we have to to to deal with
something which it's a news in sometimes
but
we are living in this let's say regular
regulatory environment
so regulatory requirements some of you
may know
have some let's say typically unexpected
effects yeah so
yeah you don't have too much time to
prepare for it and sometimes you make
ask yourself does it make sense but you
don't have any chance
uh to to change it you just have to
accept it so
the the let's say desire of of of
regulators to
look into the marketplace understand
the the intrinsics of of marketplace
especially risk time engines is is key
time to market of services and cost
efficiency well this is
something which is um not always a nice
exercise
because sometimes you are forced
especially in my current role i'm
responsible as a business cio
for uh the cash and derivatives i.t
um just a second on that i mean just to
give you a flavor
of the dimension we have roughly 500
people working there
and let's say my teams are responsible
for everything which has to do with
trading so cash and derivatives trading
with clearing risk management and data
warehouse which are the core components
and typically you have a relatively long
life cycle of these applications
so we are talking here more in
dimensions of let's say two digit
numbers of years
so these these applications or systems
and applications tend to stay for a
while
and cost efficiency and time to market
is something
which um contradicts sometimes so
in the past we tried another i think
this is just
due to the fact that exchanges are
typically
companies with deep pockets at least in
the past
nowadays this has changed quite a bit
and also new
in the past we could maybe buy the time
to market so
just throw enough money into a project
and you will make you will meet the
deadline
this is not functioning anymore because
we don't have the money anymore we don't
have these
immense budgets yeah for for spending
two or three digit
million figures in in in system
development and then operating them for
whatever 10 15 years or so
cost efficiency um
the first reaction which let's say which
comes from management this is sometimes
what i i i'm not sharing always with my
colleagues
uh is is the perspective of oh cost
efficiency means
we have to find cheaper hands and i'm
saying no guys
you can have cheaper hands in some cases
but typically there's a price attached
so
for all of you who made experience with
outsourcing
projects uh it's in theory it works nice
but if you look at the end-to-end cost
perspective so you have more friction
you need more quality insurance
structures you need more service level
agreements and so on and so forth so
it's a
it's a it's a lot of friction around it
so if you compare
a a especially when you look about the
let's say whole application life cycle
when you look end-to-end
the let's say the benefits of
outsourcing
uh are then not not always materializing
in the way you expect it yeah so i think
that this is also one dimension so for
me
uh the question is what can we do what
can we do else
so for me it's the the in the mind it's
like let's say operating a factory and
in the same fashion that you are
operating a factory the question is
not necessarily what you do the question
is
how you do it and also in terms of of
industrialization
i think that in some areas of i.t
our let's say industrialization level is
quite high
in other areas is quite poor so we're
still
let's say in this manual working
approach where you produce the car
piece by piece and and basically the and
you you're basically
doing the chassis by hand on wooden
frames
um the the second human domain
is we have a massive shift from
monolithic architectures so i spoke with
one of my
colleagues who was there for many many
years and he said you know what
in the past many things were easier yeah
so
you had somehow a close environment
and everything was in there you don't
have to deal with with too many products
with too many standards too many
languages
you just had cobalt open bms and somehow
you built everything yourself
which was fine because you know
everything and these teams were very
proud of developing functionality was
not
was not there but this nowadays is
simply not possible anymore
and also it's a matter of lifetime or
life cycle that we have to decommission
our existing open vms systems
what happened then is somehow let's say
that we
are shifting to a heterogeneous uh stack
and systems
um in this case linux java sql which is
and python is
missing there but i mean the point is
that it's it's we are moving
to a far more complex world so we have
to deal with with complexity
and this creates a significant challenge
for rit and what do we do
typically well if we have one analytic
system that is a closed box and it does
does not
do everything we would like to while we
add another box
which is different and then we plug it
together
now when you look at our and i haven't
dared
to bring a map of our systems here um
probably uh my board would kill me um
it's just just an enormous amount of
systems that we have yeah so over the
time over the years
this has grown yes you have many many
systems which are niche systems
connecting systems
they do specific things they have been
developed with one methodology another
methodology another methodology
they somehow function but but the whole
process gets
gets terribly complex and
one thing that i have experienced myself
and this is maybe here the latter part
the what i called here the empowerment
of the business analysts
or technology empowerment of the
business analysts well nowadays
technology
does not end in i.t operation it starts
already when people are creating their
first ideas
and what i will dive later a little bit
deeper into it is
how can we manage that and also i wanted
to reflect a little bit about
the experience and i mean eve said it
nicely that
let's say we started with with partner
deutsche berso group several years ago
and i wanted to share our experience um
what let's say we we have observed and
the potential
for python as a universal this was then
basically the title of the presentation
universal tool for entertainment
development
so very briefly about the agenda i
wanted to give you
a quick overview about deutsche
bersergroup
um one experience i'm making regularly
when i'm coming to london and i'm
um checking in in the hotel and then
they asked me what was the
company name deutsche deutscher bank
yeah so
deutsche birth is not known yeah in in
so far
or surprisingly surprisingly uh let's
say
it's surprising how uh in how many cases
people say
deutsche berser what is that um
then a little bit of history of of pipe
within within
deutsche bursa group for me
again not not maybe a a pure academic
approach but just let's say
um poking into into the the python
universe and trying to
understand myself where are we where are
we there
um and then maybe the part which which
bothers for me
bothers me most and which is the for me
the most interesting thing
uh in our own application environment is
the potential of python in the software
factory
while then somehow looking forward where
we where we can go
so very briefly um
sorry from from top left to bottom left
so it's this circle here
um the the the the tradition
uh of the exchange in frankfurt is quite
old i mean it goes far beyond 1820 but
1820 was of
let's say the first share traded in
frankfurt
so and let's say you see then several
years afterwards the
this building was built which is the
exchange building
um it's it's looking different today but
um
let's say it is still the same building
yeah so you see that
it's very spacious it's luxurious it's
it's it's it's just like a
more italian palace maybe than anything
else you would not expect a marketplace
there
um and this is then 1914
within within the building this was
basically a reunion
of of the exchange members uh and let's
say
then later on you see here in 1960
this was the um basically a trading
meeting
uh for for for forex contracts in in
1960s in 1969 there was somehow a break
if we want uh with technology or not a
break it was basically a disruption
that which technology started which was
i didn't found the right picture i just
take one which
uh it was was close to it um
is basically that was the first chance
to enter
orders uh and enter trades
electronically so this was a change of
paradigm
and then and this was for me amazing the
pace in which things are changing
and this is then this is floor trading
um
so deeply still deeply active here in
the 80s in frankfurt so this is
a small picture here of the old
trading floor in 97 we started then with
the first electronic trading system for
the for the cash market
and this is today so
it's there no no humans anymore yeah so
this is
uh at least not in not in the box so
what is today i mean if you go to our to
uh to our office building and i don't
want you to
to put a picture there i mean you can
see it in the internet um
it's just one building like many of
those so nothing special
so where is the market where's the beef
yeah so it's here
it's it's it's in the data center we
have several data centers for
for for protection um and failover but
but basically when
it's i have visited our data center
a few months ago and to be honest it was
quite boring i mean
the guys from the data center they're
quite happy when they can show you the
large wrecks and the cooling systems
especially the cooling systems were
fantastic i don't know how much power is
in there but
at least i understood that if you if
they would put you into this
basic cooling system you would freeze
within seconds yeah so
um and and it's incredible that you're
running there this this
let's say box if you want of machines um
and the point is that our
members basically connect to it so they
do the same
yeah so um the the let's see what what
happens is that nowadays
trading uh in the market is far more
driven
yeah by by quants than maybe
20 years ago and um you have software
engineers you have
you have network specialists you are
talking about
about squeezing out um the the last
nanoseconds so so we are not talking and
especially when you look at the hft
so especially when you when you look at
the latest developments
where our members are heavily investing
in fpgas and things like that so really
to squeeze out the last bit
a bit of speed to be ahead of the market
and react
in in this incredibly short of time
short time to to market events
also briefly what we are doing just to
give you a rough
um perspective i think what is important
to understand
this deutsche berser has one strategic
advantage with which differentiated from
others
is that we have the end-to-end
value chain so really from from trading
clearing risk management we have
derivatives we have cash settlement
collateral management market data
we own indices and we have a
let's say let's say a large technology
section within deutsche berser so
overall it has approximately 1300
employees
so it's not that small and also we are
operating a large network
which many maybe don't know but
um it's it's already huge i mean we are
we are let's say in many at least in all
financial centers but but also worldwide
we are connected
uh even to the virgin islands yeah so or
cayman islands um so
the point is that we have where where
there's a member so paradigm is
where remember is we want to connect him
yeah so
this this was the the the paradigm of
isil is the paradigm
and um this sounds well it's okay i mean
420 participants is not that much um
the reason is that that typically
exchanges tend to go to the
professionals yeah so
let's say all the firms here around the
large banks and
investment firms they are trading us but
it's not not retail typically so we're
not having so
we don't need so many clients in the
brackets don't need
and also business is quite focused to be
honest
focused europe most of our businesses
coming
from europe especially london some
business out of the states
in some some products even significant
business and then
let's say further reaching in the asian
time zone
and there this is a different dimension
to to to really um become a successful
successful player in the in in the in
this region here
you have to do different things so the
markets are far more protected than they
are
uh for example in europe so you need to
establish corporations
establish let's say market if you want
market links
different things then let's say purely
connecting members to trade your
products
i don't know if you know if you know
these charts some
typically they are quite public but i i
thought it was would be interesting to
see
um let's say what happens here in our in
our markets
so the the blue line here is
the number of transactions um i think
the resolution
it's intra month yeah so i don't know if
it's daily but but at least this is
let's say a very good
or a good um let's say perspective
but important is the red line yeah so
this is the
average response time of the system and
response time is round trip yeah so
you're sending
an order into the system and the order
the system is telling you okay i process
the order yeah
so and you see here a dramatic
dramatic decrease this is this is urex
so this is the derivatives trading
system
um so what what is important to see that
say we had a dramatic decrease here in
response time
and this is due to the new technology
that we introduced so
up to here this was our old vms system
and here we introduced our new linux
based
system which uh let's say it's worked on
distributed architecture
and far more scalable and as you can see
here yeah it's it's we're talking we
have around about
at um 200 microseconds
round trip time this is our cash market
system
which is doing fairly well
even though the let's say the number of
transactions is typically slightly
slightly lower but not that much
um except in in peaks and this is a
different dimension which you don't see
necessarily
but let's say here what you see it's
relatively stable around
one millisecond and this is basically
the state of the day
now you may ask well one millisecond is
fair enough
um the point is that markets today
markets today
are looking for arbitrage so the point
is when when an engine and algo engine
uh sends an order uh or or looks for
interest into a market they're sending
them
a for example an immediate or cancel
order to different markets
then basically if you are not basically
executing this order in the fraction of
a second
then the order's not getting to you yeah
so the markets
are going for for let's say speed
optimizations are trying
to find the best opportunities also
between markets and also in terms to
optimize their strategies
so quick history of python within
deutsche berser this is a personal
perspective
um basically it starts here so for me
when the when the first thing which
brought me to python was basically
this year the sec proposal for issues of
asset-backed securities in 2010
where they proposed that let's say the
the models of
these these securities would be
documented not only in paper
but also in executable uh python code
and this struck me so i said why they
are doing that so what is what is the
what is the
the rationale behind it and i start
digging a little bit and interesting
wise
there was some rumor around this there
were some firms which are well known
which are producing also
um financial engineering let's say
workbenches
which wrote large letters to the ssc
they're by the way public so you can
look it up yourself
on the sec website and let's say
basically criticizing
that the sec was doing something crazy
like
two basically two things first um just
saying you have to use one language
and second to say oh you go for open
source
we have no support no documentation
you're completely let's say
at your own yeah um i don't think that
i have to go uh i have to convert you
here so so i think it's it's very clear
that this is
it's it seems to be a model uh that that
worked yeah
so then i was moving forward and
we started then in 2010 and and i was
then um already a while active
um and responsible for the um for the ux
pricing strategy
which is far more analytics as you may
think about
and we have tried everything so we tried
all the tools
i can basically starting with matlab
with r
mathematica we even tried a few things
doing in c
sharp and so on so forth so we tried a
plethora of tools
and for in every dimension we somewhere
sooner or later came to a point where
say well it's not really doing
everything what we want
so it was quite quite a time where we
say okay
what do we do here and this is when when
we basically developed in 2010 or we
started then with this incident here we
started in 2010
to uh try python and i have to say it
was
um let's say a fantastic success
and thank you to eve yeah who supported
us very much in this
uh this venture um we are still using it
today
and with more and more and more let's
say enthusiasm
uh and and and use i think for the for
the firm
um also together with eve we developed
here a project i will show you some
slides as well i mean you know them
for those who attended yesterday eve's
presentation um
about uh restocks validation models
based on
by say a web interface we'll come to
this in a minute
and today i'm focusing more on the
factory perspective here
so for example one of the projects i'm
currently looking at is python 4
for tool consolidation in the data
warehouse and
um we'll come to this in a minute in
other words
so and then 2014 for me is the year
we're saying more to come
and the question why i started here is
that i discovered this
a few weeks ago so basically when when
just walking around the organization and
saying hey guys
just try i'm trying to find out who's
using partner in the company
i found out that there is a massive use
of python
in our development already so it's it's
not only you well it's basically used as
a glue language
but also as an automation language and
so on so forth
so just very briefly um in our
let's say especially this is our latest
greatest system here he said called t7
trading seven uh you may ask why seven
uh it's not eight it's not so it's not a
lucky number
but uh our marketing specialist said
that seven is a good number for whatever
reasons yeah so
it's called d7 and it's short yeah and i
think that the germans for those who
like audi
i think i think germans have a tendency
to to to this combination so one letter
one number or so so it seems to be
seems to be a german attitude um
okay i don't have to to spend too much
time here you see that we are somehow
more or less across the board using
heaven intensive usage of open source
technology this is a very involved slide
but i just
um i use the original slide which is a
presentation from from
um from the development team they made a
while ago
and i was was surprised basically uh
what they did so far
and um they have developed their their
own
um python framework which which is
called oscar
so optimize scripting architecture
for those who may ask what is optimize
well this is the project name
for for for this was the project name
for t7
in the early stages which has been
introduced for
um one one of our subsidiaries which is
the ise in new york
um which basically they introduced there
was a first introduction of this new
technology or
new trading system and oscar is
basically used in the
in the background for many things
especially for testing
and what they did is they say you know
what i mean to test such a system
which is quite complex you have let's
say a lot of functionality in there you
have to deal with many issues and so on
so forth
latency is a point so they said how can
we
automate this so they built a say like a
framework of tools
so for example what i found interesting
what they called
d2g which is a data driven script
generator
and what it does it talks with the
system interfaces
yeah so it just sends if you want
messages to the system interfaces
and the point is that you have typical
test cases you want to do
yeah so sending a certain order type
awaiting the response what the system is
doing
entering data and so on and so forth so
so basically
in order to test it you can see here
that there are over five 5.5 k
test cases and the the steps of these
tests are quite
quite complex and what they use in order
to make it easy to maintain is basically
using
a spreadsheet where all the test cases
are defined
and then use uh let's say the spyuno
maker language interface to call it
wirepipe so one application again
typical
patent application again building on
existing frameworks extending leveraging
existing frameworks and interfacing
to the market and then here other things
like
autopad our automated performance tester
tools for operations this opcon which is
a
major process console which is again
built on the oscar framework
so again here's also building you can
you can very nicely i don't have to tell
you that
it's basically a framework on framework
and and nicely reused functionality
which people developed already
i don't want to bother you too much with
pricing but i thought it would be
interesting to give you a flavor
why we came to to python now
in a nutshell urex pricing is not well
fitted for a spreadsheet
so this has been done in the past and
trying to model
uh to model pricing in a spreadsheet and
you may ask well why the hell you have
to model it well
the reason for that is that it's
relatively complex um
and i mean we probably could spend an
hour talking about about the the
the the the pricing of urex but just
very briefly
you can see it's very involved yes we
have a complex logic
you have volume rebates for those who
are providing volume
you have market maker rebates different
schemes different products
so you have a plethora of products you
have many many contracts per day you
have to deal with
and you need to monitor carefully
especially what your market makers are
doing
so why are market makers so important
market makers are those
who are providing prices for the screen
yeah so this is what you need in such an
electronic market
that you can obviously continuously see
there is something there something
where you can trade on yeah and these
guys
as they are having significant effort in
doing that so it's not only technology
they have to understand the market they
are taking risks so market makers
market maker firms i don't have to tell
you especially in london have a long
long tradition so typically there are
two
two spots where you find the top market
makers which is either amsterdam or
london or
the other way around and of course other
things like etc
pricing clearing pricing connectivity
pricing which comes on top
so we heavily used python for for
modeling
and analyzing uh pricing and and just to
to let's say just just an examples
what i found quite if you want
representative of the logic
is first thing is deal with large of
data i think this is one of my
former colleagues who's i may have to
say he's a he's a mathematician
and he programs very nicely yeah so he
always documents everything so therefore
i took his code yeah so maybe it's not
represented but you see here
very nicely documented um and he
describes exactly what he's doing
yeah and and i i find it's funny here
that it was his way basically
uh we use hdf here yeah for for which
intensive use of pandas and hdf
and that even let's say 10 million
records it's just a snap
yeah so so deal with it it's very fast
and and it's very efficient
and here it's just one um fraction
of of volume calculation you see here
the complexity
that you have to see when you want to
understand what happens
so maybe one word about that pricing is
not so interesting
for about let's say what happens today
yeah this everyone knows you can just
look it up the question with pricing is
what would happen tomorrow if you change
something yeah so
and then for that you have to understand
very
very good what you're doing to the
market so will they change their
behavior
if you change something and if they do
will this go into the positive or a
negative direction
or in many cases when our discussions we
had with
the large hfd firms where they were
saying hey guys
look into this contract you are too
expensive we are doing so many millions
of contracts a month
and so on and so forth and if you're not
trading here we're going to trade the
whatever s p 500 or any other contract
so
so so you're on ongoing let's say
confronted with
requirements of saying uh can we do
something and with all this complexity
um you can't really uh do it
on working on averages or doing
assumptions you have to model it
completely so what we did is we
established a very large
modeling framework where we are capable
of basically modding modeling
a variety of pricing scenarios using
also monte carlo simulation and other
things
and this is maybe not the the nicest
charts which is not always
so we don't need uh too often many fancy
3d charts and so on so forth but this is
more
to give you a flavor i removed here uh
the
the the member names yeah but you see
the different products which is
this is the ftx this is the euro stocks
um
and to see the impacts here on the the
reba
rebate uh per contract in in cent for
one of the pricing proposals that we're
in discussion
so 20 minutes ago that's good so um
one thing you may know already but i
just wanted to iterate it for those who
don't
uh this is one let's say the next
initiative we did with with python with
with
support from eve which was um
also from from let's say a sales
marketing perspective
of saying how can we open the doors to
our products
i mean trading the point is that trading
and outright
let's say whatever equity option is
nowadays not that sexy
out or trading an index future uh i mean
this there there is no there's no rocket
science behind it
and um the question was the the the
when we develop or as long along the
development
of more complex products so volatility
product dividend based products
whatever let's say our product
developers come up with
the typical approach was well first we
talked to those guys who already know
the game
and even if if we have this community of
8 000
traders you would be surprised how
let's say how small the number is of
those who are trading these niche
products
and then they need typically there are
these guys who know this product
from every dimension and they are then
market makers or whatever
but the point is we wanted to to open
the door for
more so for for people who are
interested in this product
so basically saying creating one spot
where you find everything yeah so you
start with data
you you have the knowledge behind it and
then finally you have your python code
you can just take it away
play with it and and and basically do
your own
research and do your own modeling so
this is if you want the the first
um initiative in in this regard we
started
um and this is one of the screenshots
here from our
web interface you can we'll find then
the the links everywhere there so this
is a backtester
where it's it's maybe let's say
maybe a simplified perspective but it's
already let's say showing for
um for a part or at least uh
specific groups in our community and
also looking
beyond our membership so typically by
side and other
other groups of interest let's say what
the effect of such a
volatility future would add to a
portfolio
and there you see here this is the
volatility future
this this is the this is the index and
this is basically the combination and
you can play around and do this
interactively so very nice
uh basically all that all done in in
python
applications within the data warehouse
without going in too much into detail
just to give you
also a flavor of this is still work in
progress
um where we're coming from uh and where
where what like
where i'd like to to to end or go so
we are coming from also here um
relatively implicit
if you want monolithic components it's
it's heavily based on on demand and sql
also to the customer
yeah so the the typical format of our
database data warehouse today
is large processing chunks you have to
do
let's say very um let's say very timely
controlled batches and so on so forth
and the customer
be it internal be it external typically
calls or sends an email and says oh i
need this data and that type of data can
you do this analysis and so on so forth
and and these are the different areas
where i believe we can add value
so one thing is the context here of the
python interface
to the to to the customer so let's say
import statistics so some have a library
where you can easily say get data and i
think all of you know
other examples in the market quandl for
example so something where you just
plug in call this library and you are
there and you can call the data
consume them and work with them and and
this in a very
uh unobstrusive unobstructive way um
automation again we can do more there
and also the the consumption here so how
can
uh customers work with it ipython
as one example be the ipad notebook or
other services
which could work on the spaces and
especially here
it's a little bit cleaning up so we have
a long history of
as i told before i told you before of
complex heterogeneous systems so many
languages many tools and so on so forth
and this is one of the things we want to
strive for instead of having
one guy who knows the perl part of of
the applications the other one who knows
whatever php the other one knows and so
forth so basically it's
creating synergies by by leveraging the
people and saying hey
just use one convenient framework and
just
one convenient let's say a language that
that
is powerful enough to do everything so
be careful you're not running out of
time
so very briefly because i think you all
most of you know this
for me it was just surprising to see how
successful python is here
uh in popular websites so just um
dragging here some some statistics from
from the web
so not only small small or interesting
wise not not
rather the small websites but rather the
large
so larger websites are using obviously
pipe and popular
a python is or python is popular there
and we have here
of course the let's say the standard
frameworks um
which i which can be used for that also
for me
interesting was to say okay uh how is
the the development from
let's say a developer perspective and
saying what happens there in the market
and i find it quite interesting
that without too much fuss here but but
uh this is python and it's doing quite
well
and it's it's it's let's say has the
tendency to to increase
um whether the others languages coming
from of course a much higher
level are are decreasing here
also looking at the repository here pi
pi
um what was interesting for me is to see
that we have
this is what interests me most let's say
financial insurance and science and
research
and there is an incredible large number
of packages already there so that you
can find
for your solutions and this is very
important especially when you have this
paradigm of
let's say not not having a closed shop
software instead using open source that
you have sufficient if you want
sufficient momentum behind it and you
find a solution for
for for the challenges you have faced
also some interesting distinct here from
from olo statistics
um seeing here the number of
contributors
and and you see here the the velvet dark
velvet line
uh is python so python is doing quite
well there it's increasing as well
and also the number of projects
obviously for whatever the spike here is
uh seems to increase whether the other
are quite stable so
again partner is doing well here yeah so
also from that perspective
and also a little bit the let's say
somehow it's a list
of of libraries where not all of them
but but but
uh most of them we are already using
and the fun let's say the nice thing
here that it allows
from really from simple simple things
simple um
let's say solutions to quite complex
financial applications
and this is where i believe is the is
the main
power of python and the existing
frameworks it allows you exactly that
and and this is why this is relevant
we're coming to a minute
which is basically the core year of of
the the presentation so why
why does it bother so why do why should
i bother why should
a software factory bother about the
language so it's it's it's um
it's a point is that it's important to
have the right tool set and here
the point is productivity efficiency i
already mentioned this yeah so having a
language which which fits
everything or almost everything is is
simply
a very good solution you can
if you use it early you have this
benefit of testing and failing fast
it's multi-platform i don't care where
it runs
um time to market uh so so if i have a
short learning curve yeah this is
beneficial because i can
easily more easily let's say allocate
people to a specific
domain and a specific challenge and i
can focus on the task and i don't have
long training and and learning sessions
iterative approach it is a massive
benefit especially when you are in an r
d mode and we are a part of it in r d
mode so not everything is just
straightforward programming
uh and of course let's say the rich
frameworks which are around
and then maintaining the degrees of
freedom one of the strategic decisions
that deutsche burger made which is quite
substantial is a massive move from
vendor lock-in to open source and
the reason for that is that with vendor
login this only makes sense
if the vendor is always ahead of you so
implicitly this means that i'm buying a
framework a software framework i'm
paying
for a software framework but let's say
by definition
i'm only using a fraction of it because
once i'm getting to the border of
the the barriers of this of this
framework i'm having a problem i don't
own it
i can i'm have no degrees of freedom to
change it
um and and also for me the change in
paradigm somehow made click in my my
brain
a few years ago and i said hey why the
hell uh
should i pay for for expensive licenses
if i can have invest in people
and it's also this investment in people
i believe is much more valuable and it's
much more scalable than
than investing in in software licenses i
think we have
i have my 10 minutes warning ahead so
give
let's go on so i can skip this one this
is stolen from eve but i mean why
why python yeah so i think this is
nothing nothing new
um very briefly on the value chain
so this is a traditional value chain and
today
we are very good here so we have we are
using already model driven software
development so the
the developers here and operate
operations here
are quite well interlinked yeah so i
don't see a problem here
but we have we have problems on this
function here
so where the it faces basically the
business so this is the area where
specifications are
written where the if you want the
process the production process starts
and this is the area where the ideas are
generated yeah and you see here
there were still we still have some
systemic breaks there that will produce
a lot of paper we have long review
cycles so large documents you have to
read
and then when i ask people hey your
model is not consistent document it
states 99
probability and in your model you have
99.5 probability and the answer is well
yeah
i didn't find the right chart so i don't
know how to update that yeah because
so so i think this is simply not not
state of the art
so where i want to go is to have a at
least
for some applications if you want
problem domains
a python development framework which
goes end-to-end
reaches out to business and uh is
capable of running
in production and basically comes bottom
up yeah this is
this is important
so and this is um
this is something uh say at least um i
think the quote i stole from from eve
from one of the presentations
he gave in in our house in november i
think
because i i still think that there is
potential the point is
if you have such a framework you can
easily extend it to the market
so again import statistics so why not
offering
so import whatever deutsche berser
interface yeah so or urex
so the point is why not offer something
what the market can't consume
what is let's say if you want is one
framework and and say it's supported by
by
one very active community and yes you
still have
areas where where you need your specific
tools and you will not change the world
in one day or another
but at least it creates potential and
creates for this popularization so
saying
this is something which is let's say
more used which is light what people are
happy to to involve
with it and this is the if you want the
area of new
members of new people who would be
interested in using that
so almost on the spot
this is the end no it's not so uh
there is no holy grail yeah so um when
when let's say you you may say well okay
this sounds nice and you will you throw
all your software away and do everything
in python no of course not
but it can it can do a lot so it's not
the holy grail
but it's rather that yeah so um it's
it's useful it's multi-paradigm it's
flexible you can do almost everything
with it and it fits in so many niches
that simply by definition it helps you
to to solve problems where
you would have no immediate solution
right away
and um i don't have to convince you i
mean it's it's also fun
i mean the the they're not so many
languages it's like speaking a language
or learning a language
maybe you have a tendency to learn those
languages where
you feel more comfortable and and i
think that partner is one of those
so to end my presentation and leave at
least some some five minutes
for questions to to keep the schedule
so basically making the whole round back
so to the start the universal ad tool
for enter and development
so patent is a good basis
it can help us to solve many challenges
we're having today in the financial
industry
not necessarily limit to do it but but
let's say this is my my perspective
this multi-purpose paradigm is valuable
so
it's not doing a bad job in all these
areas it's maybe not the specialized one
and yes in some cases you need some
micro seconds to to to take out but i
think that
let's say this is also let's say this is
solvable
and it creates synergies and this is for
me most important when i when i see the
different teams
are thinking in the same on the same
grounds that they're starting to reuse
knowledge
and and to talk about this readability
what i meant before with the language
it somehow fits the brain um it's fun to
work
and i'm fascinated about the this
community and how fast it evolved in the
last let's say three to four years
i think this is covered by force or
frameworks are there
and for me this is some of the vision
i'm having is this end-to-end usage so
starting on the quant side and this is
of course
tailored now for the financial industry
um
across basically the the whole it value
chain
down to the operation of these systems
and basically way way back so providing
data back to
providing services and value back
uh into this into this community so
my final statement today is and this
i think it's it's also an important
signal deutsche berser has included
python in its technology stack
so in our it roadmap where we defined
let's say the
technologies for the next whatever five
to ten years i don't know how long such
a technology
roadmap stands but at least it has the
aim to stem stay for longer
and we will definitely use it as
an really integration technology and
end to end and this is basically the end
of my presentation
thank you very much
hello hi you've talked about the pi pi
server
and so the pipeline packages are not
digitally signed
how do you address the security problems
that uh that come by using that
um it's a it's a good question the point
is we cannot just
use the software straight away we have
to look very carefully
where we use it so if we use it for
internal purposes
i'm not bothering too much from the
point onwards would
use something for our members probably
would have to shield that
and spend more time in protecting it and
also there is
liability involved so we have
as a market operator we have a role of
let's say and this is
defined in germany at least by public
law so you have to guarantee that let's
say what you're doing is functioning
also the regulator is looking very much
at it
so we would have to take care of
shielding basically the loopholes which
are in the used packages
indeed thank you
you have much into pi as
your implementation for python
is it for meta programming in
python no my understanding is that the
developers
use it as the driver between the
spreadsheet
and our own implementation our own the
oscar is the
testing environment and basically this
is the interface so that we can
we can just use a spreadsheet as an
input
yeah um
uh so you mentioned that you'd like to
or it's an
interesting goal to extend python usage
to
outside clients of your business have
you done any research into
uh all like thought about training and
how feasible it is to move people in the
city away from you know spreadsheets and
towards
actually programming basic things
yeah we have um this is a
is a challenging task um
and and i have to admit that this is
maybe the same thing like it's not the
holy grail yeah so
a lot of people and users still use
their environment they are
like and which is typically heavily
spreadsheet based i think it comes a
little bit with
i would say the other way around i don't
have to convert them
they will let's say typically convert
themselves
when you encounter a problem we cannot
you cannot manage anymore
so i see that let's say um when you deal
with these
that's a large amount of data so we say
the pricing analysts for example
and also the guys who are developing our
risk models and they have to deal with
millions of data records you can't do
that anymore
last question yeah so there is a
definitely a gratuitous use of
spreadsheets in finance i put my grocery
list in excel
but i think there's actually a very rich
tool chain available in python
for managing spreadsheets if you look up
data nitro there's a technology called
dynamic filament that will allow you to
dramatically simplify the
operational side of actually managing
questions
you can embed python in excel using vpn
okay so if there are no no further
questions i think that we can oh there
is one okay
do you use uh python on the high
performance side of your business let's
say if there is any limit to let's say
python speed or something like this do
you refactor code
to any other language or something like
this
well for the time being we don't use
python in our
let's say low latency environment so
this is
handy-tuned c code typically and we are
there we are trying to exploit if you
want the last
bits of using the right compiler
using the right operation system version
and so forth
and the right libraries in there so it's
not there
but the point is it's not everything is
low latency yeah so again i mean for
some
some areas you you have let's say the
right solutions
but in some areas where you don't need
that and and and
when you look at the at the development
time or the the budget you are investing
i'm surprised when you look at it
project end to end
you are typically spending a significant
proportion of the budget of the
of the project in the early phases yeah
so designing it
and and and thinking about the content
so if you really take this into account
which is not just
it does not start with okay dear
programmers drt
please do that this is the documentation
go ahead and implement that
it results rather early and there i
think that you can
somehow have an iterative approach where
it comes from both sides so one have you
have a framework
in the group that you can use you can
build on that you can develop your risk
models on real data
and while yes if you encounter a
specific area where you have
problems with latency or speed or data
whatever then you may tweak
this but this isn't just one fraction of
the effort and on the other
side try to do everything um in in other
languages proved to be
far more effort yeah so for the same
code which takes in
in python whatever three four lines it's
in c
plus plus i don't know how many yeah but
i've seen some cases where
let's say simple tasks have been so they
are so tedious and the point
is that from my perspective now running
such a factory
it's a legacy so you're carrying always
this risk that you have a lot of code
sometimes people are writing things in a
duplicate fashion yeah because
it's not such a so if you want it's not
not such a tradition of using
and sharing frameworks maybe there are
some which are better
but others maybe not oh another one
i think hopefully you have to say when
it stops as a
mic maybe the last question
uh there are a lot of technical things
you can overcome my experiences
the most problems are probably in the
human space do you have any experience
about what are the big
resistances of people adapting python
and because usually
have experienced people that use
something smarter systems for a long
time
they had some hard time converting to
something new
did you encounter any of those problems
to be to be honest no
um i mean what we do is we probably do
some let's say we also evangelize a
little bit so we do
information sessions we have we had our
patent day last year in our own house so
i initiated the python day
where um they we we had
some some good presentations with eve
and travis
travis presenting there if he's there
and and let's say this is somehow
starting so we are
trying to if you want mobilize people by
motivating them not by forcing it
yeah and it works and i think it's it's
a self
self propelling momentum um and
at least i'm not encountering this
problem